as you kind of think through uh the end
of the year what's your price prediction
anything change to uh to what you're
looking at i mean same same as we've
been talking about for for months now
but uh you know that the top model sits
at like 111k um woo has a top model
that's like at 193k but mine's a bit
more conservative um but of course as
price it's based on mean reversion and
then also the um kind of the
cost basis of investors based on realize
cap um and so you'll you'll you'll start
to see that slope up if price does as
well but for now that sits at like 112 k
why is yours uh more conservative it's
just a different way of of calculating
it so willie's takes the all-time moving
average or all-time moving cap of
bitcoin and then multiplies it by think
37 or 36 and a half
and then mine is mine is looking at
delta cap so you're looking at
the difference between realized cap and
the average cap and then you're
multiplying that is the arbitrary number
and this is the one we looked at like
two weeks ago and i just said it's a
random number i picked seven and a half
multiply it by that you've been able to
catch some some tops um just as you've
been able to clip the the
like macro bottoms um so yeah i like
delta cap as like a conservative way to
to look at kind of mean reversion and
then also your your
because you have average cap which is
where i'm saying the inner version is
coming from and realize cap is where the
cost the cost basis of investors is
coming from so
got it and then in terms of uh time
series so a lot of folks look back in
2017 and right in the heart of december
was the top of that bull market it also
happened to be i think like the day
after futures were approved to actually
start trading um but do you think that
the bull market runs through the end of
this year or do you think it will
actually carry into q1 of next year i
wouldn't be surprised if it if it
carries out till q1 and next year
because of some of the the supply
dynamics and how long that those have
taken historically to kind of play out
um and also like anecdotally hearing
about some people that may be sticking
their neck out of the woods um i i don't
know how long that period of perhaps
announcing announcements will come right
like i don't know if that's just like a
chain thing of they all kind of come in
you know sequentially like week after
week after week and then we just blow
off top or you know do we get one like
every month or so and
i don't know i think there's a couple
different factors that make it really
difficult to look at the timing but in
terms of like some of the investor
behaviors we know kind of what to look
for in terms of gauging you know how how
close we are to getting to these
overheated zones what is your thought
process about this bull market that
we're going into right now in terms of
uh what is your price prediction for the
end of the year or how high do you think
that we can go in the bull market yeah
uh you know tough question i love it um
i'm wearing the 100k hat i think that
comes fast honestly uh once all-time
high breaks like people kind of gawk it
at big numbers but again like you have
to look at bitcoin in the log chart for
a reason um and when we break these
all-time highs i think it's going to be
similar to kind of the price action we
saw after uh 20k broke we flirt we
flirted with 1920k for a little bit and
then a month after the all-time high
broke we were at 40 000. so i think i
mean maybe maybe that doesn't repeat
exactly but uh it's going to trade it's
going to trade very very reflexively
it's going to go parabolic and a lot of
people you know are going to kind of uh
you know it's going to melt faces and so
you're going to have a lot of capital
you know flooding into this this asset
and you're going to have not a lot of
people selling especially early on so
you know i think we're we're at you know
six figures or close to it by the end of
the year and i i i'm pretty confident
that it it's not just you know gonna
stop there um you know bitcoin is here
to stay i i completely agree do you
think that the bull market runs through
the end of the year or do you think
it'll actually extend into like q1 q2 of
next year yeah i think what a lot of
people are you know when you're
comparing it to 2017 um just like the
cycle by cycle thing or by havings what
people don't really understand is we
kind of had a full bear market condensed
into like three months so we had you
know we had massive derivative
liquidations everybody that was
leveraged even like you know people are
saying oh bitcoin never goes down 50 of
the bull market i'll just 2x long
everyone was wiped out you had a massive
minor capitulation kind of engineered
politically by china you had a huge like
puke up of spot uh coins that you can
literally see on chain that were already
accumulated so we kind of had like you
know this this traditional like
three-year bear market that we always
have like or that bitcoin's had you know
a few times we just saw that in like a
pretty condensed amount of time so i
think you know in that sense it's it's
super bullish and that we kind of just
like charge back up to run it back um so
that's why i'm like hey like you know we
might not we might not talk here in 90
days and i might this this cycle
might not be so much of a traditional
four-year cycle and it might you know
continue to just run on as bitcoin is
you know now it's it's here to stay like
all these these fun like boxes that i
was saying were checked off well you
know everybody in the world is looking
at this thing you have presidents
tweeting about buying the dip like we're
in somewhat of a new paradigm here and i
hate saying this time is different but
in the sense of bitcoin's not going to
go down 80 and and die for three years
i'm very confident in that so i think
that the tradition of a four-year cycle
like will said earlier uh you know i
think that that might go away what's
your year-end target price-wise
128 000.
all right why such a specific number
uh i know uh i know will was using like
some kind of quant stuff and math i use
the delta eight to get to my number
what's the delta eight
i can't wait to hear this one
if you don't know what delta eight is
i'm not gonna get into it this may be
the wrong show
all right oh so 128 000 you think that's
it
yeah we're gonna hit 128 000 by the end
of the year but uh i think we're going
you know north of 200 000. i look i hope
we go north of 200 000 by the end of the
year i got some out of the money calls
that uh that need to get there i got two
two hundred thousand and three hundred
thousand
options that expire december 31st
sorry i i would love for it to go higher
than that guys but we'll see